hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review i have uh another
review for you that i post uh this this
evening
so on this cambridge audio um cxa81
i think it came out a couple years ago
i'm not quite sure
um it was sent to me i think brand new
from a
owner that bought it and drop shipped it
to me
and it cost about thirteen hundred
dollars u.s
cambridge if you don't know it's a
british company and although this
products made in china as a lot of
products are these days
um in the past cambridge audio has been
a sleeper uh product in in my reviews in
that you always look at them they sort
of have this understated look but they
tend to perform
pretty well not state-of-the-art but
always better than i expect them so i
was happy to get this integrated
amplifier and deck to see how it
performs
once i put it on my desktop and you can
see it over here um i was disappointed
in this user interface
a lot of times for selecting inputs
on on devices either you have a rotary
selector or you have a button that
cycles through and if you're going to
use automation to select an input like
you have a home control system that's
pain in the neck it's better to have
random access
and
they've done that to some extent using
these buttons in that you can select an
input by just clicking on it but
strangely they've overloaded two of the
buttons if you're familiar with that
term in computer science meaning
same user interface has two different
things they can do in this case if you
push this button on the right which has
a bluetooth and some wiggly thing that
looks like usb if you push that once as
i did
you think that you've selected usb input
but you haven't it actually defaults to
bluetooth is selected you have to set it
click it one more time then it turns
orange and becomes usb
to me if you're going to provide
random access why then all of a sudden
have this be cycling through two inputs
same with this a1 analog input one if
you just press a1 it selects the rca but
then you have to press it again to
select xlr balanced input so i found
that kind of annoying um
it's neither here you know it's neither
one type or the other type uh you know
they couldn't decide and then it's got
the speaker selector amb which is i
don't know how often people use this in
the 70s and 80s that was a popular thing
to have two sets of speakers but i'm not
sure how many people hook up two sets of
speakers maybe again they think of home
automation we have a separate set of
speakers on a patio or something
anyway um the volume controls analog
which is unusual in this class and uh so
that means not a rotary control and they
that has good and bad and good that you
can see the location of it and that
tells you how high you've set it
um bad things that they tend to not be
very accurate usually unless they're
really hand-picked
volume controls and and you'll see later
on that there is some balance issues
with with this
but the biggest thing for me with
disappointing was that i expected some
kind of this informative display over
here this big glass area and i thought
you know it would tell you maybe what
you select an input tells you the sample
rate or tell you the volume control or
something information but nothing's
there it's just all blank and for
thirteen hundred dollars and you have a
microsoft array that that handles these
things you know show some information in
here and have some blank not that it
impacts sound quality but i sort of
thought it was strange that you know
there was nothing here
excuse me
um if you look in the back um
you see the dual set of you know binding
post for the
left and right channel
um and then i appreciate having balanced
input as i mentioned the xlr inputs
um going back to the front actually you
see this big rune indicator over here
roon is the media player i use a very
nice
high-end player
i won't get into the details of it but
when i saw that i automatically assumed
this was a streamer which means that i
can hook it up to the network and i can
play push content basically from room to
it then i go in the back to try to do
that and i didn't find an ethernet jack
and i didn't find wi-fi antenna and then
i realized that it has neither that has
no streaming functionality at all and
that this room thing just says this room
tested which i assume it means tested as
a dac
which is kind of what to do uh just
about any dac that's complying with the
class drivers and windows and mac are
you know compatible with roon anyway so
yeah they went through some kind of
certification with roon but
that doesn't tell me anything so i i
thought that was misleading on this but
yeah the product doesn't say there's a
streamer but when you see
you know room roon that's multi-room a
network capable player you think it's
going to have streaming capability
capability and it doesn't
typical of today's silliness in
protecting people is that these speaker
terminals come with these uh banana
plugs that are
covered with these little tabs um
half the time they're very hard to
remove especially if you don't have you
know sharp nails to get on durham
and these were quite hard to get and get
them off in that they were just so flush
that i couldn't get them off so
typically what i do when that's the case
i just unscrew the terminal all the way
out and then the uh
the little tab is done easy to just pull
out as i try to do that with this the
tab and this end terminal were moving
together so that wasn't going to work at
all but while i was doing that i noticed
that the shaft at the screw of that you
know banana
plug that goes in there it was so thin i
mean it would look like if you just put
a little pressure on it it's going to
bend and break
i've never seen such a thin
screw terminal for such a large you know
banana
plugs or jacks i forget which which
gender switch
but anyway it was just very very
surprising uh for something that's
thirteen hundred dollars a big box from
a higher end brand to have i don't know
the cheapest ones i could find in here
so even after you tighten them they sort
of like still wiggle
you know minor things this doesn't have
enough power to worry about power loss
in there but i just worry about
durability and that stripping and i'm
breaking so
you know it didn't inspire all that
confidence uh it seemed like you know
somebody was out to uh
uh cut costs in this thing
the advertising is kind of you know
typical marketing although you know i
want to encourage companies to be more
truthful about this stuff and uh here we
can see that it says designed and
specified without compromise really so
no compromises at all all right we'll
see about that and then the whole story
every detail nuance to deliver
delivered intact and in full
unparalleled accuracy really
uh
unparalleled uh what is their reference
on this thing but maybe it's like other
products have tested uh and it performs
uh very well so let's get into that
i with multi-function devices like this
i divide them into subsystems and i'll
test each subsystem separately so let's
start with the dac portion this has usb
input and spdif and toslink i only
tested it with usb although for the kind
of measurements you're going to see
you'll see that that basically their
performance will be the same
and um
the uh convention i have is the desktop
dax and and are put out two volts on rca
output which is on the preamp output on
this device and this goes back to sony
and philips setting that standard with
cd prior to that rc output could be
quite a bit weaker but they set a
standard of 2 volts for rca and 4 volts
for balanced
so that was 40 years ago so i expect
companies to be with the program
and allow 2 volt output fortunately this
uh the cambridge uh cx a81 does that and
actually it can go up to about five
volts output five point and change
so but what's not so good is that when i
said it's just two volts out of five and
a half volts they can get to look at the
harmonic distortion that i'm getting in
here massive amount over here and the
third harmonic and these higher harmonic
orders are quite loud so we could argue
maybe second harmonic has massed uh
easily but as this harmonic go out there
masking power of this signal gets weaker
and weaker and so
this is just totally unacceptable it's a
completely different leak than than it
should be and you'll see later on um how
it manifests itself but anyway we have
the highest peak in here around minus 75
that means 75 degree lower than this
signal itself that we told it to
reproduce the one kilohertz and that
sets this sign add value cyanide is
basically some of distortion and noise
relative to our signal
and sometimes noise dominance sometimes
distortion dominates sometimes both
dominic in this case distortion is so
bad that forces sign out to be 75.
this is extremely poor uh performance
but before i sort of evaluate it further
let's look at what's happening um as far
as output i can digitally change the
input to the
dac and watch the output voltage and
then plot the sign out which is what i
was just
explaining and as we go from you know
let's say this is 0.4 volt output
performance is climbing getting better
and better and this is typical because
the signal gets stronger relative to the
constant noise that's in the device and
you see that it gets up to about 1.6
volts then also index massive noise dive
and
that's bad
now why is it doing that why doesn't it
keep climbing like this
usually in this uh the only reason this
typically happens is that the power
amplifier in this unit starts to
saturate and it starts to clip and when
it does that it drags the rest of the
machine with it
i had no speakers plugged into it so
there was no real real power delivery
going on and
it shouldn't have happened they should
have designed the amplifier to have
lower gain and require more input and
push this point up to two volts at least
if not higher and then this wouldn't
have happened or in audio video
receivers then i'll have a
switch setting on the better ones that
say turn off the amplifier i'm going to
use an external amp and you don't want
the internal amp to clip and kill the
machine
what's the point of having a preamp
output if it's bound by the limits of
the internal amplifier because at this
point if the internal amps clipped you
can hook up 1000 watt amplifier to it
and it would also clip at the same 80
watts or whatever this thing can produce
so really poor design but at this point
the best case would be about 96 db
synapse which is
basically what cd can do so after all
these years uh you know 40 years after
introduction of cd this thing struggles
to produce noise floor and distortion
that's at the limit of cd format and so
it's just not acceptable just give you
an idea state of the art devices produce
a signed out of 120 db 122 db
so we're like uh i don't know 50 db
lower i mean just insanely lower this is
not just two or three four or five six
db it's just way way lower uh at two
volts output uh in here at 1.6 is more
reasonable but at 2 volts you're getting
way less than cd's performance so very
very disappointing in what it is by the
way look at the two waveforms here
they're not landing on top of each other
means there's a channel balance issue
and you can see it in here the two
channels
one has slightly lower voltage than the
other and that's the problem with the
analog part depending on where you put
it
you get different levels of channel
imbalance with this kind of performance
that they're having they should use the
digital volume control because you know
those things degrade performance a bit
but they're held a lot better than what
we see in here anyway so it wouldn't
have been the limiting factor
next we can just measure the dynamic
range with the two volt output and
basically what we get is cd's 16-bit
dynamic range there are a bunch of
advertising from a company saying that
it's high-res and this and that well
certainly just pure noise level is not
high-res uh on this thing so it's just
not a great thing and that high noise
floor comes to bite it when we do our
intermodulation test
this test has a combination of 60 hertz
and seven kilohertz so it measures
distortion simultaneously for low and
high frequencies at once but it starts
with those two signals very weak and
gradually raises them to full amplitude
when the signals are weak noise is
actually contributing a lot to the
general
badness that spits out of the machine
and here we can see the performance of
cxa81
and this dashed orange line is actually
a nine dollar phone dongle uh from razer
and so you can see that the noise flow
on general performance is dangerously
close to a nine dollar item uh that you
know there's a headphone amp to those
things and uh now that device starts to
saturate and gets distortion early um
the cambridge keeps going and the
distortion gets quite low but before it
can get to the limit of our two volt it
saturates and distortion shoots up this
worse than the dongle so
that's just not
competent performance i expected land on
top of our yellow reference which is a
three-year-old uh 200 dollar deck and
headphone amp topping the x3 pro
expected to be close to this
uh and state of the art would beat it
here we're not even in the same planet
in here we're almost 18 db worse as far
as noise on this thing
disappointing stuff continues uh in here
um when i run this jitter test all we
should see is this spike
at 12 kilohertz and a few little tidbits
in here i won't get into why
but instead we have the all these spikes
in here the all that multiples of one
killers which could be the usb packet
noise and then tons of other
interference below it we see this jagged
and raised bottom in this thing
state-of-the-art deck that noise floor
would be down here
so
good news is that it's not very audible
these spikes are very low levels versus
our threshold of hearing
you know it's but
you know we measure we want good hygiene
in design and simply not there
a lot of the tests have been single
tones but we can measure 32 tones
simultaneously
and here we see that basically the
distortion free range we have is 16 to
17 bits
the reason this is better than our sign
ad in the dashboard is because this is
not saturating the dac output the output
of the dac is less and as a result
the dac is hasn't saturated so the
distortion is good
better than the dashboard but
as far as grand scheme of things is
terrible state-of-the-art decks easily
go to 22 bits over here and here we're
short six or seven bits and we're in
again cd rates as far as distortion uh
so not very good
i measured the reconstruction filter in
in dac and i'm going to get into what
that is but ideal that would have a
cutoff right at this
red line vertical line but many dac
chips at like the ess stack chip that
this uses they have a gentler filter uh
and uh that's okay it's sort of instead
of rolling off at 22 rolls off at 24
kilohertz uh on this so not bad it's
just typical practice so i can't blame
them too much on this one but choice of
how that filter works and combined with
noise and distortion impacts this
measurement this measurement
goes up to 90 kilohertz uh bandwidth so
it's actually including the ultrasonic
uh noise that the dac may be producing
and so that noise in the distortion and
and
any other outer band components that are
in there if you sum them all up and plot
them you see this red line in here the
reference i have this this hadas tone
board which is a was great at the time
was a 99 deck
board that came out three three and a
half years ago and it was just great at
the time today many dags beat it but
look at the performance over here so
this machine can't even remotely come
close to being competitive with with
this 99 dollar board stereo deck so
you can see how disappointing this is um
let me go back make a meta point uh a
lot of people walking around these days
and say oh sign that doesn't matter why
do you care about this number why is it
important we should just ignore china
it's like the worst thing in the world
when i look at this dashboard i almost
always can predict the rest of the
measurements we're just looking at
cyanide and just looking at this one
graph
once you give me a cyanide that's this
low means two things that every analog
engineer should be good at what not
which was to reduce noise and distortion
if you don't care about noise and
distortion audio design becomes held a
lot easier but what separates crap
engineering from good audio engineering
is that you try to minimize noise and
distortion because both of those are
unwanted unwanted signals you're piling
onto on top of my music
so
when i see that those two components are
not taken care of
i know that the design hasn't benefited
from having any kind of proper
specification in advance somebody didn't
say hey look we want to have noise and
distortion below the cd and even better
because we're going to advertise we have
high res playback up to 24 bits and what
have you
clearly there was no such target and
whoever designed this either didn't
measure it that well didn't care or
it just was
just indicative of the fact that this is
not a properly engineered and qualified
and quantified design
that's what cyanide tells you this is
how much good engineering has gone in
there if somebody was sloppy about uh
noise and distortion the top two things
an analog engineer worries about then
you can predict the rest of it's gonna
be crappy too and indeed we see it okay
so oh wow you know we saturate two
we can see the noise is not that great
we see the intermodulation distortion is
not great this is a different
measurement than cyanide but shows the
same kind of thing shows the saturation
jitter yeah if you're not going to care
about uh it's plain noise and distortion
should say not going to worry about
jitter either
multi-tone just confirms what we already
know this one's a little bit different
but this test again it could have
predicted that it was not going to be
great because it just it isn't you know
the sign had already told us that so
cyanide's incredibly great
as a predictor of how good a device is
that's why i usually plot it although in
this case i didn't i put in a table and
show it to you and you could literally
step back and say look i don't
understand any of these other things but
if a device produces a sign out of 115 i
guarantee you the rest of the tests are
going to be extremely good
once in a while there's an exception but
that's rare that's like one out of 50
where the cyanides great and the rest of
it isn't or vice versa almost always
sign it is a great predictor
of engineering excellence and again
those are two things we care about we
care about noise and distortion you know
jitter oh gosh you know what are the
circumstances under which we can hear it
and what have you
okay
um this is an amplifier so this was sort
of the appetizer the dag testing was
maybe as great as an amplifier before i
jumped into the power amplifier
measurement uh there's a preamp output
and there's xlr balanced input i said
well i want to treat that as a pre-amp
analog preamp which it is
let me just measure that performance i
uh usually adjust the gain in these
things to be uh
again 2 volts output rca output
input was 4 volts so that worked out
well as far as the volume control
position and look at this now again uh
we're back to the sign out of 75 db so
the analog section of this thing is just
as horrible also maybe the dac is great
and it's the preamp output of this thing
is the limiting factor i don't know but
you know this sets the limit for how
good the amplifier can work because we
haven't even started the amplified
signal from before we just screwed it up
with all this distortion over here so
and again you see a channel imbalance
with these two waveforms not matching so
moving right along
it is a power amp so let's measure it my
standard for power amp measurement is
measuring it at five watts the industry
standard is one watt that goes back
decades when power was very expensive a
30 40 watt amplifier was a good amount
of power today you laugh at a 40 watt
amplifier so
i if you measure just at one watt what
you get as far as the sign out is almost
always just a noise uh dominated thing
distortion never rises enough to care so
you're basically measuring signal noise
ratio
out of this fancy dashboard why do that
five what five what to me is a much more
reasonable power you could literally
listen at 5 watts to an amplifier but
chance of you listening at 1 watt is
very low so i always i've standardized
on 5 watts since the beginning of time
i've measured probably 170 amplifiers
now using the same standard the second
thing i do which is tricky business and
i've standardized on this um it comes
from uh what do you set the gain to
where do you set the volume control
because i have control over how strong
of a signal i send it and where i set
the volume you know which let's say the
input high and volume low or volume high
set the input lower and every app is
going to have different gain structure
and different performance so
um i resorted to a little known standard
called from thx the the brand that you
know a long time ago they said 29 db for
home theater products for the amplifier
to have a nominal gain of 29 db so
basically i adjust the volume until i
read 29 in this dashboard and then i the
input to get
5 watts so that's usually around 0.15 to
0.16 volts
i put that in there and i get 5 watts
what's that once i have that then i look
at two things again just like the deck i
look at the sign ad and i see 69 db in
here and i shake my head the average for
these 170 amps that i've measured is 78
db not 68 db so a 10 db better 10 db is
a huge number that's a log number and
it's it this is like really really down
in the sort of poor category to be that
far below average not state-of-the-art
state-of-the-art goes to 105 and plus uh
we're talking to like really bad
territory in here uh you can buy a
little chip amp for 50 bucks from amazon
they'll run circles around this uh on
this and you can now you say well that's
just one number maybe you know what do i
care about cyanide well then look up
here you can see where that comes from
this noise floor is quite high and that
is what's killing the asyna distortion
is around -90 db so kind of reasonable
power supply noise is worse actually
although our hearing is not very
sensitive to that noise but overall this
noise floor is quite high and we can see
that
at five watts our signal noise ratio is
exactly our cyanide or 68 dvs and what
does that translate to in dynamic range
in bits
if you think in digital it's only 11
bits
so if i'm listening at 5 watts and i've
got a true 16-bit content that i'm
playing
this
amplifier is adding five bits worth of
noise to your signal
there's just no reason for that um the
target i have is 96 db i'd like to see
96.
many amplifiers hit 90 91 and some
state-of-the-art once hit 96.97
so i like to basically clear cd's hurdle
96 db is the dynamic range of cd and at
5 watts it is a tough target but boy you
know 69 versus 96 with you know 30 db
short so you can't remember the piece of
log scale now a lot of this is because
of the uh flat noise level nose floor of
the device there's this much noise in
there when you just put that much power
in it that noise dominates so i then
measure also what is it at full power so
i measure the amp right before it clips
and i measure the same thing again so we
see that as we turn up the volume indeed
that ratio gets better and but we still
have 13 db so if he's blasting this at
full power which i think is 140 watts or
so um it's uh still not close to even
having the dynamic range of
of
of a cd what does that mean if you have
sensitive speakers or you sit close to
them you're gonna hear the noise of this
amplifier coming out of your twitter
most likely and that's just not
acceptable i mean
you gotta make things quiet i don't
understand why they've built such a
noisy device
um again a lot of our testing is one
kilohertz but we can feed the 32 tones
all the way up to from 20 to 20
kilohertz
and i don't remember seeing such a high
noise floor in a long long time i mean
you've got to build a really really bad
amplifier for the bottom of this graph
to be this high usually the bottom is
weight heck down here here we have this
noise and it actually gets worse and
lower frequencies
if we count the tip over here to the
bottom and sort of guess that where
these all distortion unwanted signals
these spikes in between uh sort of give
them credit you know that it's probably
around here we get in about 13 bits and
if you want to get really hardcore and
count the tips over here it's down to 10
bits so anything
lower than that is going to get stumped
on by this intermodulation products so
you know it's muddying up your detail
whether you can hear or not i can't tell
you but i tell you objectively is
stepping on any detail you have at that
low level
in the co bad measurements there are two
good measurements uh thankfully the
frequency response flattened good in
outward band and bandwidth is wide this
also tells me it's not digitizing the
input so you know as it shouldn't be
it's an analog device but just in case
we know that it's a pure analog you can
see the channel imbalance again with the
two lines not matching
crosstalk um
measure down to one kilohertz because
usually crosstalk is a capacitive
problem where there's capacitance
implied capacitance um between the two
channels and then the signal at high
frequencies jumps and bleeds into the
other channel so that's what crosstalk
usually you see it run from 20 kilos
down and below one kilos we usually
don't care because it that that coupling
doesn't happen as as easily but here it
started off really good this is actually
slightly above average then all of a
sudden we got close to one kilo instead
of shooting up so
that tells me it's got some kind of
inductive coupling i don't understand
what's happening and where that bleed is
coming from uh as far as audibility is
not important though you know this is
huge minor channel separation uh in that
so
you know it's again engineering design
hygiene did you keep the two channels
separate from each other or are they
mixing signals from each other
um
power is a big deal you know if you
don't have enough power your amplifier
can clip and then you can sound really
bad it can get harsh it can get noisy it
can get static here and it can shut down
completely why because as soon as the
amplifi this kind of design because
there's limit distortion goes through
the roof if you just push this thing a
hair passes clipping point
nice your sign add is minus 20 db so
you're jumping from sign out of 80 to
20. so
it's you better stay away from this uh
knee of the curve because it's extremely
sharp and so
you want your playback to never swing
that far so how much power you have is a
big deal um with four ohms load i get
119 watts right at the edge of this uh
clipping point 120 watts and then
running the same test with eight ohm uh
test we get 85 watts but look at how
high the noise floor is
when the graph is pointing down is
dominated by noise not distortion and
this is indeed dominated by noise look
at my worst case which is this nad avr
which has really bad performance and
this thing is almost as bad as the worst
thing i've ever measured on this most
you know mass market products even have
a graph that comes is somewhere in
between and this blue state-of-the-art
for the 8 ohm one is the purify
amplifier and benchmark is what i use
hp2 that i use for in the forum
as an exceptional amplifier is the
cleanest amplifier i've ever measured
look at the gap in performance in
decibels again a logarithmic scale look
at how i mean it's just not in the same
planet here
um good news is that if we allow one
percent uh of distortion
and i run the power test again at 12 at
uh
um with forum load uh we get up to 120
watts which is this this back uh
actually no we get up to 140 watts and
the spec is 120 watts so it actually is
better than its spec so whoever designed
the amplifier power supply and or the
amp power stage did a good job
if i use a burst uh um
tone where it's low apple juice and it
just so it gets loud and goes back down
it shows even more headroom and up to
174 watts and this can be representative
of music playback because music is not a
continuous sine wave
and then i run one final test which is
i run the power sweep just like you saw
with the forum one except that now i
cycle the the
frequency
so we now have measurements in addition
to one kilohertz in blue we go all the
way up to 15 kilos all the way down to
20 hertz
and we're looking for performance that
actually kind of looks like this which
is is frequency independent there's no
new sources of distortion
due to that it's a little misleading
with this amplifier because it has so
much noise that we don't see the
distortion ever till it clips so if it
had less noise let's say it was down
here we may have seen things going up
and down as far as distortion but we
don't um so i would say we don't know
how good it is if the you know if the
noise wasn't there but just take it at
face value yes it's good to be like that
and at 20 hertz you lose some power
because this is the orange one eclipse a
little earlier but that's very typical
of amplifiers because 20 hertz is such a
lazy uh sine wave that it keeps the
power requirement high and the amplifier
runs out of juice
earlier on this day
so
what's the conclusion the conclusion is
disappointment uh i've never tested a
cambridge audio product that performed
this poorly so far below his competition
uh
and uh thirteen hundred dollars you know
thirteen hundred dollars you can
assemble the pieces for this
that uh that perform the same
functionality for far less money uh for
three four hundred dollars you can get
state of the art amplifiers for
dollars you can get a dac
uh with bluetooth in it and
yes you won't have a preamp so you know
you if you have multiple analog inputs
you need the preamp also but uh
it just doesn't make sense the other
thing it doesn't make sense to me just
functionality and usability of the
device
just the user interface lack of it
information and blink display the
build quality externally at least just
not satisfying to me so very
disappointing on this uh
you know they had a great winning uh
streak in there uh let's see what the
membership is voted so membership is
kind of harsh uh we have 92 it's like
it's a horrible product and agreeing
with me that is a headless panther uh uh
product and uh only one person thought
it was the next category and everybody
else said no good if you want to vote uh
you gotta join audio songs review then
you too can vote and see if you can
override my my ratings for a product
okay so uh
uh
very disappointing here i thought for
fun i'll show you a review that they
could from what hi-fi which is a british
audio magazine that's online
and uh i got a kick out of uh
the test code in here on the sound
quality says confidence is key to the cx
a81's performance confidence
what on earth is confidence
hammering out staccato rhythmic patterns
with a short conviction
an amplifier has conviction
i had no idea that amplifiers had souls
and had human beings in them with
convictions
snapping in time
snapping in time what what is it doing
how do you snap in time and allowing its
expert handling
of alternately loud and soft
beats to lock in a groove
is he thinking that it's a turntable uh
that's that's tracking well it's not
jumping to track
it's just stunning to me that this kind
of nonsense is passing for an audio
review um
if you look at the ratings in here the
sound quality is five features is five
build quality is five
what on earth are these guys evaluating
i mean it's not hard to unscrew a
speaker terminal look at how thin it is
and how flimsy it is it looks like you
could just snap it off
on this thing what how could they say
build quality is great how could they
say the features are great this class
product should have had streaming built
into it should have had ethernet and
wi-fi at thirteen hundred dollars
100
not having stream internet this day and
age in 1300
modern amplifier it's just not
acceptable you need to have that and
then for that you have to have a proper
display that shows you what you're
streaming it doesn't have that and the
sound quality if this is how you measure
sound quality is this nonsense that they
just run through some kind of program
that auto generates this kind of
verbiage
it just makes no
sense astonishingly detailed
presentation really with all that
distortion and noise that it has
of course you know who knows who's doing
this review i don't think there's even a
person that's uh listed in here
uh doing the react they don't even tell
you who the author is just take our word
for it they didn't even take a picture
of it using a stock picture from
cambridge audio so um
you now know not to uh trust this site
uh there is a going uh gossip that they
tend to being european uh you know side
that they tend to like everything
european so you know if it was a u.s
company producing the same thing uh they
would give it the lower rating
but uh regardless it's just totally
totally just folklore is what they're
talking about bold powerful detailed
presentation expert timing and dynamics
ah the blood pressure can go way up
reading stuff like this
anyway i hope you learned something in
addition to
getting inside into the performance of
this device
i'll see you in a future video bye